[Music]
max is with us in salt lake city hi max
welcome to the ramsay show
that's your ninja i mean i appreciate
you accepting my call sure what's up
yes sir so i'm a 50 year old married now
um been married for about seven years i
believe
we could retire um but i'm
not sure if we should
okay what's the what's the goal here
what's the goal what do you want to do i
i guess i guess that's the concern um
we've been we've been very fortunate
we've played by the rules um i've had a
spreadsheet budget that each tab goes
back all the way to 1999. wow um
and so i have if you it's kind of like a
link leading the rings on a tree if you
go to a certain tab you can kind of see
what happened in my life
in that specific year
um but we have four rental homes uh we
have one one pension already secured and
we receive that each month my wife works
and i also have another career now
we should get a second uh pension uh in
five years when i'm 55 through the
military
um and so i guess and what is your net
worth
honestly i i don't know uh when you
account for our full rental home so they
are paid off uh we live in the fifth
we've been a fifth wheel for about five
years now so that we can make uh have
cash flow through the rentals um i would
estimate probably 600 650 000
net net
net worth
um and i guess the biggest concern and
you hit it on the nail on the head when
you said what's the goal um each what i
have found that
for a
very long time now i've always had woken
up and had a goal had something i wanted
to achieve had something i wanted to you
know
a medal i wanted to put on my chest or
something i wanted for my wall
um
i never thought that uh 50 years old i
would kind of be lost because i don't
know if we should go for a fifth home
i don't know if we should just call it
good we're making now uh 14 14.2 a month
net
our total expenditures each month
outflow are about 2.3
um
and i i
i kind of had this wild dream of i'm uh
i've been a private pilot since i was 18
so 32 years
and i was talking to my wife that maybe
maybe someday i can take about 35 000
and go after a a instructor reading and
maybe i can do that part time
until basically the faa says
i'm too old to do it but then i don't
think i'm going to make the return on
the investment if i did that i guess i'm
just looking for some
something to wake up in the morning for
[Music]
but but the money's easy that the
numbers are easy um
but now that we're here i don't know
yeah
i do want you to change gears though
from doing your duty
uh because you're a man of honor who's
always done his duty
to uh finding something that you make
money doing while actually enjoying it
and i don't care if you make a lot of
money it wouldn't make me mad
the challenge about the questions
the challenge about the question you're
asking max is you've roi joy
you've put a spreadsheet to what matters
and you you've spreadsheeted out
relationships you've spreadsheeted out
excitement you've spreadsheeted out
happiness you've spreadsheet of joy
and
it's very hard to capture those things
with it with it with a ten key
and
the
challenges you're asking a question what
what can i go do what can i go seek
that's going to fill that gap inside of
me and
that's going to come from the inside out
not the outside in
so the question dave is asking you as a
profound one what do you want to do man
yeah and so here i'll give you a hint
okay
um
i'm gonna send you uh ken coleman's a
career assessment and his new book from
paycheck to purpose because what's
missing here is purpose
um and uh
i'll give you a place to look
find something where you're serving
other people and making their life
better that makes you smile
and then i want you to do that with
great scale
and go make a million dollars doing that
because you're only 50. you've still got
20 or
25 good hard years of work that you can
bring value to other people's lives
and um by the way if you do that in a
proper way inside your skill set
they will give you as my friend rabbi
daniel lapin says certificates of
appreciation with presidents faces on
them when you serve others and make
their life better they are grateful just
like when you have a great
experience in a high-end white
tablecloth restaurant
you are more than happy to
say thank you to the person who served
you by leaving an outrageous tip
and that's the way the economy should
work is when we serve each other
there's a transfer of wealth that
results and i want you to get that
um
because you've just been grinding
on my notes here dave as he was talking
you could see the word i wrote i wrote
the word service
oh i just wrote that word down as he was
speaking
the only way out of this trap is to go
be about making somebody else's life
better and it doesn't have to be a
non-profit nope
um
you know we can argue that steve jobs
like him or not like apple or not made
lots of people's lives better with these
magic wands we carry around in our hands
called phones
that we can do anything with now
and uh became bazillionaires because
they made a lot of life people's life
better and we can go on from there or
something as silly as you were with me
at a park a few uh maybe a month or two
ago and your wife and henry cloud had to
peer pressure me into getting on a
roller coaster because i'm scared
terrified of heights that's my that's my
thing
and the other day you and i jumped out
of an airplane together
um with a guy with parachutes with
parachutes yes we made it but
otherwise we would have left our mark
but somebody left it all on the field
served us laughter and joy and
overcoming fears and that dude was
incredible and he kept us safe and he
walked us through it that's a service as
far as i could i mean it was it was a
thing they were incredible incredible
the team
you know made skydiving not terrifying
yes yes which is less than i can say
about you pulling us on a tube behind
your boat
but here's the deal i was trying to
serve you sir you
you served you up to the water i'm about
18 lake water right now yeah but service
can look like a lot of different things
but it's going out and saying where can
i bring people joy where can i meet a
need in the enviro in the world that's
not being met and go do that thing for
other people
all right
absolutely
yeah that that's going to help in this
situation so mathematically you can do a
lot of stuff
you've got some pensions and you've got
some margin and you've got some net
worth
and you've got time
um i do think you need to change gears
oh i'll tell you the book you ought to
read i got it it's called half time
by bob buford
and um
bob the thesis of the book for those of
you that haven't read half time it's an
old book it's a great book
is that
men particularly males
when they reach half time in the game
they go from acquisition
to significance
and if you don't move from acquisition
in the first half of your life to
significance in the second half of your
life
if you don't make that move uh you're
susceptible to midlife crisis is blondes
and convertibles wow and so you're going
to find significance doing something
you're going to find excitement
doing something in the second half first
half is just grinding and acquisition is
fine and by the way the first half is
not a chronological thing it's an
emotional thing i did my half time at 28
when i went broke
and so i reached the point after going
broke i don't give a crap when anybody
thinks i'm gonna do what i'm supposed to
do i went to significance which is this
thing has been i've done for 30 years
now plus 30 plus years
so um been on the air for 30 years
but uh uh the uh but that's that that
whole movement there's a movement there
that's tied to the midlife crisis idea
and all that kind of stuff but you know
you're just having a uh chronologically
a little bit later half time and doesn't
mean you're emotionally stunted that's
not what i'm saying but this guy you
know that we're talking to here max but
i i think you know hey
you know what's the next adventure yeah
look for an adventure of service a man
without a purpose is an untethered scary
dangerous
person go find a purpose man yeah yeah
go sir hang on i'll have austin pick up
we're going to send you a copy of that
um
can call all kinds materials and
assessment and the book as well from
paycheck to purpose